über die neue hightechwaffe die ihr da
hinter mir seht und auch anderes
militärisches Gerät über die Auslastung
über die aktuellen Zahlen und Bestände
sprechen wir jetzt noch mal und zwar mit
militärökonom Markus Kolb der mir wieder
zugeschaltet ist
hallo ja diese sogenannte glsdb
präzisionsbombe die soll ja von den USA
an die Ukraine geliefert werden und
diese Bomben wurden bislang lediglich
getestet aber noch nie in einem Krieg
verwendet in wieefern könnten die denn
jetzt den Krieg vielleicht auch
entscheidend beeinflussen
also das stimmt so nicht gr small Diana
the bombs sind jetzt nicht gerade eine
neue Technologie sie sind die
Kombination von zwei verschiedenen
Elementen und die wurden auch
tatsächlich in Kampfeinsätzen bereits
verwendet also es wurden historisch etwa
20 000 von denen gebaut und etwa 10000
wurden davon bislang in Kämpfen
eingesetzt also vielleicht kurz wie muss
man sich das vorstellen ähm diese Waffe
besteht aus zwei Teilen äh zum einen den
M26 Raketenmotor
ähm und der stammt eigentlich aus einer
älteren Generation von von missiles und
diese missiles die haben früher
klustermunition getragen und als man die
klustermunition ähm durch das Abkommen
über die Streumunition weitgehend
verboten hat da haben alle Länder ähm
die diese alten M66 messils hatten äh
ihre äh clluster Anteile zerstört aber
ähm was man aufgehoben hat sind die
Raketenmotoren also spricht der der
Antrieb und auf der anderen Seite
gibt es aus der amerikanischen
Entwicklung also genauer gesagt von von
Boeing und SAB ist das eine Entwicklung
die sogenannte small diameter bomb also
eine Bombe mit mit eher kleinem
Durchmesser und geringem Gewicht die
gbu39 und die war eigentlich vorgesehen
für Kampfflugzeuge also spricht dass sie
eben weil sie klein und leicht ist dass
sie viele von denen an ein Kampfflugzeug
dran hängen können was man jetzt gemacht
hat ist so eine Art Ikea äh Bastelei das
ist nicht neu da kam man drauf so vor
ungefähr 20 Jahren äh wir könnten doch
die beiden kombinieren also wir nehmen
den M26 Raketenmotor und Schrauben den
sozusagen an diese äh an diese gbu39
dran und damit erhalten wir eine missile
die und für die brauchen wir eben keine
Kampfflugzeuge mehr sondern die können
wir abschießen und zwar erstens aus den
bestehenden highmß Systemen also die
kennen wir ja mittlerweile alle ähm oder
es gibt sogar eine eigene
abschlussvorrichtung also ein ISO
Container und mit der können Sie das
Ganze im Prinzip von Schiffen oder von
von irgendwelchen landgestützten Punkten
also egal wo
abfeuern und wir wir kennen mittlerweile
das das heimassystem das große Problem
des heimasystems eben die begrenzte
Reichweite von maximal 80 kilomet also
von den von den missas die die das
halmystem verschießt glsdb hat fast die
doppelte Reichweite von ungefähr 150 K
also Sie können ja zu Hause mal eine
Karte sich hernehmen und wenn sie vom
äußersten Punkt des Frontverlaufs
einfach Radius Zeichnen von 150 km dann
erreichen Sie also je nachdem wo sie
sind wenn sie im donbas sind erreichen
Sie die russischen Verteidigungs und
logistiklinien und zwar in großer Tiefe
sie erreichen knapp das russische
Hauptquartier gennyesk auf der Krim sie
erreichen knapp J wenn Sie das Ganze
gegenüber von nor KKA aufstellen also
das ist schon mal ein riesen Vorteil der
zweite große Vorteil ist eben die
Stückzahl also nicht nur dass man jetzt
je nachdem welche Zahlen sie lesen so
zwischen 10 und 17 000 im Moment noch an
globalen Vorräten hat sondern es gibt
eben auch eine bestehende
Produktionslinie die man jetzt an Boeing
und und SA gegeben hat das heißt also
die Dinger werden jetzt wieder neu
produziert und ist eigentlich etwas dass
man typisch also das typisch ist für
diesen Krieg dass man sagt wir haben
eigentlich ältere technologiebandteile
also attackems z.B die ja letzten Herbst
gekommen sind auch die sind jetzt nicht
gerade neu sondern stammen eigentlich
aus den 90er Jahren und ähm diese äh
diese Bestandteile sind eigentlich im
Wesentlichen abgeschrieben das heißt man
kann die also zu sehr günstigen
haushaltskonditionen
quasi aus den aus den Department of
Defense stocks entnehmen und
entsprechend hinschicken und jetzt
nachdem was was Frau newland erzählt hat
sind die bereits in der Ukraine das hat
sie vor ich glaub vor 24 Stunden erzählt
also müssten wir jetzt eigentlich heute
oder morgen ähm die Ankunft dann sehen
an der Front und dann in den nächsten
Tagen äh auch schon den den ersten
Einsatz okay die sind also in der
Theorie gut reichen durchaus weit es
gibt auch genug es werden genug
produziert wissen wir denn wie viel
davon geliefert wird das ist ja aktuell
noch nicht ganz klar also wird diese
ganze Kapazität auch wirklich dann in
der Ukraine münden
mhm also ich ich denke der der große
Vorteil ist eben wir haben hier es nicht
wie bei attackems oder wie bei Taurus es
zu tun mit mit sehr teuren ähm Systemen
oder mit mit Systemen wo eben nur wenige
hundert überhaupt zur Verfügung stehen
also die globalen gesamtvorräte von Tams
sind eben wenige 100 Stück ne und das
gleiche stückzahlproblem haben wir ja
auch schon diskutiert bei Storm Shadow
bei bei scalp bei Taurus besteht das
nicht so sehr da haben wir vielleicht
500 im Moment aber trotzdem sie sehen
die Größenordnung ne x 100 versus X1000
bzw x10000 und insofern äh würde ich
sagen ich ich kenne die konkreten
lieferzahlen noch nicht aber es besteht
hier jedenfalls kein kein
nachschubproblem oder kein Problem das
in in sehr großen Stück Zahlen zu
liefern es wird wahrscheinlich so
ablaufen wie bei attackems die Ukraine
bekommt erstmal ein Teil führt Proof of
Concept durch das heißt zeigt dass sie
damit umgehen kann dass sie damit
wertvolle Ziele erreichen kann und
sobald das der Fall ist wird es sicher
ein ein großes Problem der Ukraine lösen
nämlich den den artilleriemangel bei der
klassischen Artillerie ne auch das muss
man immer bisschen auseinanderhalten
artilleriemangel besteht bei klassischen
artilleriegeschossen nicht aber äh bei
raketenartillerie nicht ähm bei drohen
die teilweise die Artillerie
substituieren und ganz sicher nicht hier
bei glsdb also es ist es ist eine große
eine große Verstärkung äh der
raketenartillerie und eine die
sicherlich starke Auswirkung haben wird
ähm auf die russischen Nachschublinien
also diese die gsdb ist ist zwar sehr
präzise sie hat eine circular error
probability von etwa 1 m ähm und sie
kann auch schwere Strukturen
durchbrechen also ähm 1 m stahbeton kann
sie kann sie durchbrechen aber wichtiger
für die Ukraine wäre es natürlich ähm
den russischen Nachschub zu unterbinden
ne also s dass nichts mehr an die fronte
durchkommt genau hier sehen wir gerade
so ein so ein Bild ähm also das das ist
schon eine sehr potente Waffe sie sie
ist wie gesagt sehr leicht sie trägt nur
sehr sehr geringe ähm Sprengladung ich
glaube von etwa 16 kg ähm aber sie
richtet damit ziemlich großen Schaden an
wir sehen sehen hier übrigens auch die
gleitflügel ähm die da ausfahren al das
muss man auch wissen das Ding ist eine
sogenannte gleitbombe also sobald der
Raketenmotor das Ding ähm quasi in
rauskatapultiert hat fällt der ab das
Ding teilt sich die Flügel klappen aus
und dann gleitet die in ihr Ziel das
heißt also sie hat keine Infrarot
signignatur ähm sie muss nicht irgendwie
gesteuert werden ähm sie kann auch mit
mit reiner trägheitsnavigation ähm
fliegen und das heißt die ist durch
electronic Warfare sehr schwer zu
erkennen äh oder abzufangen ne also in
insofern ist ist eigentlich was was sehr
innovatives ähm und und etwas das glaube
ich jetzt deutlich mehr Wirkung äh
erzielen wird ähm als als klassische Art
jetzt sind ja aber gerade noch äh die
Ukraine Hilfen in den USA finanziell
blockiert
äh ja aber da da geht's um was anderes
also ähm da da müssen Sie bitte auch
immer unterscheiden handelt es sich hier
um presidential drodan authority oder
handelt es sich um supplementary
appropriation also spricht das letztere
supplementary appropriation das muss
durch den Kongress aber da geht's nicht
darum dass irgendwie der Ukraine Bargeld
geschickt wird sondern da geht's vor
allem darum ähm die amerikanische
Verteidigungsindustrie anzuwerfen ne
also spricht die den Verträge zu geben
äh womit dann das Department of Defense
wieder beginnt neue Waffen zu
produzieren während man die alten
Bestände aus den Lagern in die Ukraine
schickt aber ähm Boeing und und SAB
haben diesen Auftrag erhalten also für
für die Produktionslinie ähm und also
soweit ich weiß gibt's da keine
finanzierungspreme also außer sie wissen
jetzt mehr als ich nee wir gucken mal
wie sich das weiter entwickelt und
kommen mal zu einem weiteren Teil der
Ausstattung nämlich zum Artillerie
Munitionsmangel der wird ja dieser Tage
auch viel beschrieben es wird gesagt das
ist eine große Herausforderung die für
die Ukraine sie kann im Durchschnitt
viel weniger verschießen als Russland
jetzt ist gestern bei dem EU ureffen ja
auch noch rausgekommen diese eine
Million Schuss Artilleriemunition die
man da letztes Jahr mal versprochen
hatte die kann man nicht einhalten jetzt
fragen sich viele wie lange kann die
Ukraine diesen Mangel noch aushalten ja
ja wissen sie das das Thema
artilleriemangel das ist so immer so ein
todschlagargument das stimmt so also in
manchen Bereichen aber man man kann das
nicht so global sagen ich muss dazu wie
immer etwas ausholen also Vorsicht wir
überziehen jetzt ähm also zunächst mal
muss man unterscheiden über welche Art
von Artillerie man spricht wenn man über
klassische Artillerie spricht also es
spricht die die aus
schweren Geschützen abgefeuert wird ähm
ja da hat die Ukraine viel zu wenig das
stimmt das ist aber ein bekanntes
Problem seit Kriegsbeginn ähm man muss
aber auch sagen auch die feuerfrequenz
der russischen Truppen ist stark
gesunken also von noch etwa 50.000 pro
Tag im Sommer 22 das war so das Maximum
als sie s d erobert haben auf jetzt noch
etwa 10.000 pro Tag und die russische
die die ukrainische Frequenz liegt so je
nach Frontabschnitt zwischen 2000 und
5000 pro Tag wir reden jetzt aber hier
über klassische
Artillerie also das was wir hier gerade
sehen ne also die aus aus solchen
klassischen schweren Geschützen
abgefeuert wird es gibt aber auch noch
andere Arten von Artillerie also
insbesondere klastermunition also
dieckem dort besteht keine keine
Knappheit an dipckem geschossen und wir
reden natürlich auch über
raketenartillerie und ja da muss man ich
sparsam umgehen mit attackams und mit
highar weil es davon nicht so viele gibt
aber eben das was ich gerade erklärt
habe glsdb äh ist erstmals ein
raketenartilleriesystem das nicht äh
nicht knapp ist dass man also auch in
größeren Stückzahlen oder in größerer
Massierung äh verfeuern kann man muss
auch sehen russland hat natürlich ä ein
einen großen artillerievorteil gehabt
als sie in diesen Krieg hineingegangen
sind also etwa 17 Millionen Artillerie
Granaten das waren die kombinierten
sowjetischen und russischen Bestände von
denen sind jetzt etwa 12 Millionen Weg
ne also das das Problem Artillerie
Mangel bzw nachflug das kommt natürlich
auch auf die russischen
Produktionskapazitäten zu und das ist ja
das was ich immer sage wir sehen bisher
den Krieg immer mit einer Verzerrung ne
wir denken Russland ist stark aber
bisher kämpft Russland diesen Krieg im
Wesentlichen aus seinen Reserven also
die historischen Reserven die Russland
einsetzen kann die sind viel viel größer
als seine tatsächliche
Produktionskapazität und erst wenn diese
ganzen historischen Reserven verschossen
bzw abgenutzt sind erst dann wird die
russische Rüstungsindustrie wirklich
getestet und erst dann können wir
wirklich beobachten wie ist eigentlich
das nachschubpotenzial
Russlands es soll die Problematik
natürlich nicht beschönigen wir erinnern
uns vielleicht noch an den Sommer 22 wie
lange das gedauert hat bis man gewisse
westliche Staaten dazu überreden konnte
dass die Ukraine Artillerie braucht das
hat also bis in den Sommer 22 gedauert
ne wir waren damals noch ein zum anderen
Level und haben uns damals noch
Illusionen hingegeben ben manche tun das
bis heute aber wenn sie dran denken was
da was man damals hätte machen können ne
wenn man damals die Ukraine massiv mit
Artillerie ausgestattet hat gut hätte
hätte Fahrradkette ne man braucht nicht
über über diese diese Dinge diskutieren
weil sie in der Vergangenheit liegen
aber trotzdem muss man sich fragen na ja
wenn die EU das jetzt nicht mal
hinkriegt eine Million Granaten pro Jahr
zu schaffen wie wie wollen Sie das dann
machen wenn also angenommen Russland den
Krieg gewinnt und und dann an der
natogrenze steht also ich meine da
sollten Sie mal drüber nachdenken also
Europa ist ist nicht im geringsten
vorbereitet auf so eine Konfrontation
und täte gut daran
seine seine Potenziale so langsam mal zu
aktivieren ich glaube viele haben noch
nicht wirklich verstanden
dass wir uns hier in einer
welthistorischen Auseinandersetzung
befinden in der es wirklich um um den
Kern der Sache geht also bis hin zur
eigenen staatlichen Existenz sie können
sie können zum Glück sagen dass die
Ukraine im Moment die Front hält ne weil
sonst wä nämlich Duster sie können zum
Glück sagen dass Polen aufrüstet sonst
wä nämlich Duster also in in dem Kontext
muss man das ganze auch mal sehen es es
geht jetzt hier nicht nur um
irgendwelche Produktionszahlen die sie
ja nicht getroffen haben sondern es es
geht letztlich um die Frage wie
glaubwürdig sind Sie bei der
abstchreckung
Russlands ja und äh hier haben wir auch
noch ziemlich viele Nachfragen um jetzt
mal wieder so ins kleinere um in die
kleineren Fragen zu kommen
nach den F16 Jets wann werden sie in der
Ukraine eintreffen und was ändert sich
wenn sie da sind mhm also nach
derzeitiger Planung Frühjahr ähm also
vermutlich März April ähm was ändert
sich dann na ja das größte Problem der
Ukraine ist im Moment dass die Russen
relativ ungestraft im frontraum mit
luftmitteln operieren können das heißt
also mit Kampfhubschraubern und mit
eigenen Kampfflugzeugen ähm das heißt
die Ukrainer werden zunächst mal in der
Lage ähm größere Hoheit über ihr eigenes
Frontgebiet zu gewinnen also z.B den
Russen nicht mehr zu gestatten dass sie
die Front einfach so bombardieren können
ähm sie können stärker ihren e eigen
Luftraum überwachen das heißt es wird
für Russland schwieriger seine
Terrorangriffe auf die Städte und die
zivilen Infrastrukturen durchzuführen
also mit diesen wahlosen bombardem die
es im Moment relativ ungestraft
betreiben kann
und natürlich steigt ihr angriffsradius
ne also wenn Sie wenn Sie Kampfflugzeug
eben starten lassen sagen wir mal aus
der Region Odessa einmal rüber fliegen
auf die Krim und einmal wieder zurück
dann eröffnet Ihnen das natürlich neue
strategische Möglichkeiten Russland
anzugreifen und ähm es ist ja das was
was man immer äh gesagt hat ja die die
die Ukraine kann das nicht bedienen oder
die brauchen zu lange also nein das sie
sehen dass das ist durchaus möglich und
die Leute trainieren und beherrschen das
System auch und auch da zeigt sich
wieder was ich vorhin gesagt habe ne
wenn man früher angefangen hätte
wirklich stärker hineinzugehen und zu
sagen das ist jetzt nicht hier so ein
bisschen hinauszögern oder die Ukraine
darf nicht verlieren sondern das ist
eine welthistorische Auseinandersetzung
mit Russland und äh entweder entweder
sagen wir jetzt hier ist die Grenze ne
oder äh oder wir machen weiter
appasement ich ich hoffe man hat das
jetzt so langsam mal eingesehen also die
die Frage ist nicht ob kampflugzeug oder
nicht oder ob mehr Artillerie ähm oder
oder nicht die Frage ist Artillerie ja
sofort die Frage ist Kampfflugzeug ja
sofort ne also das versetetzt die
Ukraine eigentlich erst in die Lage
überhaupt ein Mal gleichzuziehen äh mit
den russischen Möglichkeiten was was sie
bisher eben nicht konnte und wird sie
dann letztlich vielleicht in die Lage
versehen äh versetzen also sagen wir mal
vielleicht Ende diesen Jahres
erstmals wieder mobil äh vorzurücken
also sprich mit mit stärkerer
Luftunterstützung dann auch ähm wieder
in die mobile Kampfführung überzugehen
m in Anbetracht der Zeit machen wir mal
jetzt sowas wie eine äh ja im in unserem
Sinne kurz Fragerunde es gibt nämlich
noch einige Fragen
zu Russland es wird hier gefragt nach
den Kapazitäten nach den militärischen
Kapazitäten der Russen und es wird
gefragt hat Russland in den nächsten
Monaten genug Kapazitäten um eine
Großoffensive zu starten wie steht es
denn um deren Ausstattung mhm
das hängt davon ab was Sie mit
Großoffensive meinen also die
einsatzfähige Panzerwaffe von den etwa
3000 ne von denen ich früher immer
gesprochen habe die ist fast weg also
wir sind jetzt auf 2700 Kampfpanzern die
weg sind
ähm tja die Produktionskapazität beträgt
also Produktion müssen man in
Anführungszeichen betrachten ne also das
heißt vor allem Instandsetzung älterer
Systeme die aus den Lagern gezogen
werden aber ich würde schätzen
vielleicht 150 bis 200 maximal pro Monat
ähm das reicht ihnen vielleicht gerade
um die derzeitige Abschlussquote ähm
auszugleichen aber das reicht ihnen
nicht um Reserven zu massieren also
dafür müssen sie wirklich massiv in die
lagage hineingehen aber das tun sie ja
schon seit Kriegsbeginn also wenn sie
mit Großoffensive meinen entlang des
gesamten frontbogens ähm quasi um um die
ukrainische Front zusammenzuschieben
würde ich sagen nein weil wenn das
möglich wäre dann hätten sie es längst
getan ist das was ich immer sage wenn
die russische Armee so großartig ist
wieso macht macht sie nicht einfach eine
Großoffensive und rollt die Ukraine
einfach auf ne wieso gibt sie sich so
viel Mühe und und stellt sich so dumm an
ähm also wirklich glaubwürdig ist das
nicht nein ähm dafür bräuchten sie eine
ganz andere logistische und industrielle
Kapazität ich glaube nicht dass Russland
die im Moment zur Verfügung hat mein
Statement ist nach wie vor und
unverändert Russland führt den Krieg aus
seinen Reserven solange die Reserven
groß sind geht das gut je stärker sie
abschmelzen desto weniger geht das gut
also ich ich glaube das nicht wirklich
und wir haben jetzt zum Abschluss noch
eine Frage von einem Zuschauer der die
Sendung auch mit ihnen öfter zu schauen
scheint er fragt nämlich russland hatte
den Krieg im letzten Oktober bereits
strategisch verloren gibt es ihrer
Meinung nach im weiteren Verlauf noch
weitere entscheidende Zeitpunkte worauf
wir achten sollten ja also sicher der
Zeitpunkt wenn Kampfflugzeuge zum ersten
Mal eingesetzt werden ähm also der in
diesem Frühjahr und ähm sie sollten eben
äh schauen auf die abnutzungsrate ne
also wenn die einsatzfähigen Reserven
Russlands wirklich weg sind ähm und
Russland gezwungen sein wird erstmals
offenzulegen wie leistungsfähig seine
Rüstungsindustrie äh sein wird ähm und
ab dann denke ich wird der Krieg einen
anderen Verlauf nehmen bis dahin wird
erer denke ich im Wesentlichen statisch
bleiben ja ich denke wir werden uns zu
dem Thema sicher noch mal sprechen Herr
Kolb vielen Dank dass sie da waren und
ein schönen Abend noch gerne schönen
Abend